hi everyone I realize I promised you a
video a bit sooner than this but
unfortunately a lot of things in the
going on in my life not all of which are
good we had a death in the family
smooth redundant in my relationship and
generally I've been a bit exhausted but
I am now in the final stages of
producing video on study skills which
should hopefully be out next week before
I say anything else if you're a person
watching this who has just got their
results and they weren't good enough to
get into university there is a really
important video that you need to watch
by youtuber called Lex and I'll put a
link to that here a really really good
video that you really need to watch this
video is about what I've been doing this
summer most of which involves staying in
Oxford I managed to cram in a lot extra
as well I managed to see the Olympic
torch pass through October scary by
Roger Bannister
that's this guy who run the first sub
four-minute mile in mountain climbing in
Snowdonia my friends when exploring the
local countryside around Oxford
and just this past week I've actually
been visiting a friend in Amsterdam and
most excitingly for me one thing that
happened at the very start of the summer
was that the YouTube channel which I
produced for my college spc Oxford link
here won an award from the University
for student podcasting which was
incredible actually which is why you're
actually seeing me in slightly higher
definition than you're used to most of
what I've been doing this summer though
is what a lot of people who were doing
the four year physics course here do in
the summer of their third year which is
to do a summer research project in the
physics department here in Oxford so
there are seven broad sub departments to
the physics department in Oxford
you've got astrophysics atmospheric
Oceanic and planetary physics biological
physics condensed matter physics
particle physics quantum information
processing and theoretical physics I've
been working in atmospheric physics
specifically looking at stratospheric
dynamics with my supervisor dr. Scott
osprey now stratosphere is the middle
atmosphere it's between 10 and 50
kilometres up it doesn't have as much
exciting dynamic behaviour the lower
atmosphere does like the Hurricanes and
skydivers in fact it's name comes from
the Latin strata meaning lots of layers
stacked on top of one another kind of
boring but it's not just a block of air
that hangs above the earth there's
actually an awful lot that goes on in
the stratosphere that we still don't
understand what I've been working on
specifically is two different
oscillations of wind velocity in the
part of the stratosphere that's above
the equator the wind in this part of the
stratosphere changes from westerly to
easterly back to westerly every two
years or so it's called the quasi by
Anil oscillation
it's quasi bindable because it doesn't
happen exactly every two years it
happens sometimes every 24 months
sometimes every 30 months and sometimes
every 36 months but it never has a
period which isn't one of those three
numbers 24 months 30 months or 36 months
interestingly there's an oscillation
even higher up in the atmosphere which
has a period of exactly 6 months and you
might have noticed that those three
numbers 24 30 36 are all multiples of
so it's reasonable to assume that this
might be some kind of interaction going
on there between the quasi biannual
oscillation and the semiannual
oscillation remember when we were
talking about oscillations here we're
talking about the velocity of the wind
so in other words whether wind on the
whole is going to the west or to the
east over the equator so it seems that
these two oscillations might be
connected somehow
and that's exactly what two papers want
from Caltech and one from Oxford showed
rigorously specifically the oxford paper
that showed that the two oscillations
are always face synchronized or phase
locked basically what I've been doing is
knowing that this phase synchronization
happens in the actual atmosphere has
been looking for computer models in the
atmosphere which also have phase
synchronization of these two
oscillations the idea being that if we
can find a group of computer models
which have this phase synchronization
and another group of models which don't
have this phase synchronization that the
difference is between those two groups
of models might give us some kind of
clue as to how those two oscillations
are physically linked in the atmosphere
to cut a long story short of all the
models that I looked at and I looked
over 20 international models of the
atmosphere only three actually had any
kind of quasi vinyl oscillation and of
those three only one had the type of
phase synchronization that we were
looking for so we still have a long way
to go
when it comes to modeling the
stratosphere but we do at least have one
model which does it right in this
particular instance what happens now is
that I have written a paper and the
co-authors of the paper including my
supervisor have looked at it and it's
currently being reviewed and with any
luck it will be published in geophysical
Review Letters and I will officially be
a scientific author which is like a
childhood dream I can actually call
myself a scientist which is mental
what's even more mental is that now my
supervisor wants me to accompany him to
a conference in Germany to present our
work which includes giving a 20-minute
talk on the paper which I must be honest
I'm mildly terrifying about but it
represents some
thing really exciting for me which is a
potential start in academia and that's
what I think I'd like to do I think I'd
like to become a lecturer and be able to
teach and do academic research at the
same time so this is really quite
exciting for me so yeah that's what I've
been up to and why I haven't been making
more videos though that is set to change
soon I promise
in the meantime as ever if you have a
question about anything that I've talked
about please feel free to leave a
comment on this video or send me a
message I'll try and get back to you and
you'll be hearing more from me soon